thank you guys Kirk first of all welcome
to St Louis congratulations on a big
victory for you what was the plan going
in today's round you know Josiah quite
well you guys are good friends what was
the plan for this round yeah well the
plan for this round was I was just gonna
play my cuddle on and he has almost no
games against the kotlin so I didn't
know what to expect I didn't prepare
this line at all with Bishop E7 so he
played this line with 60 takes C4 in the
classical Catalan did that surprise you
at all or for sure because I he never
played it as far as I knew of course
it's a common line but also it's a bit
of an unusual Choice considering that
he's an aggressive player this is a
solid opening after
um Queen C2 I was surprised by this C6
line I hadn't looked at it recently but
I knew a couple of you are aware of it
because I was aware of it yeah you
definitely play the most uh direct way
yes 95. I knew the position until
um D takes C5 on move 12. I'm not sure
if Knight D5 is the best move but it is
a move seems to be the best yeah it
seems to be the best move I didn't
remember what to do in this position so
I started thinking E4 is a possibility
but then after night before uh Queen E2
or queen B3 and then he'll move his
queen and I didn't like this Pawn
structure even if the engine said it was
okay it's very hard to play here for
white
what is the plan behind this Pawn
structure it feels like once you get the
pawn on e4 maybe your attack is getting
a bit slower is that what you felt well
I don't like my Bishop on G2 being
blocked in these positions it becomes
much harder to play I in these positions
I tend to try to bring my knight to E4
exactly so either uh SAC on D6 drop my
knight on D6 or play Knight C5 exploding
blacks week and dark squares yeah this
position and that's exactly what I
wasn't sure if B4 was a good move I
thought A6 was good
I would have certain I certainly thought
A6 was a more solid option for black
yeah yeah it already felt like Rook to
Seattle was a step in the wrong
direction perhaps Queen to B8 was the
best move in the position I saw Queen B8
I wasn't sure exactly what I was gonna
play here I was even considering uh uh
94 but I realized after Queen takes C5
Knight C5 perhaps the Knight B4 is a
problem yeah so I couldn't play 94 in
that position yeah but I had I have
other moves but okay it's only equal
after Queen B8 I could have played
Knight takes D5 here in an E4 like
engine says yep
yeah and just uh
make the position a bit more peaceful uh
Rook to see it
and this became a mess very quickly yes
he was attacking you and progressing on
the queen side you had this thorn in his
position on D6
how did you assess it at this point I
actually I was not surprised by my
opponent playing in such a manner
because it is a very aggressive player
and takes a lot of risk I know that this
is uh not exactly in the spirit of how
Black's supposed to play this variation
though and I also know while the
position is uh three result game I know
that with uh Bishop pair and the strong
D6 spawn I know that uh even though not
everything can concretely be seen for
both sides white should definitely have
an advantage here yeah and I think your
assessment was very precise was H4 a
good move I wasn't sure I think perhaps
Bishop takes F6 is the more precise but
H4 doesn't lose the advantage by any
means yes I was just trying to keep
tension the position but it's
interesting to see Bishop F6 has such a
high evaluation for white I would say H4
at least from a practical perspective
and don't trust this too much I mean if
you let it think for a little bit maybe
it's going to get the same levels
um I think it was a good decision
practically
Queen 24 was definitely the right move
try to get the game into the end game
and after that it felt like you never
let it go
Kirk congratulations big victory for you
guys any questions well our
congratulations as well Kirk uh keep up
the good form yeah it seems like the
game went you're away from the beginning
beginning till the end did you feel at
any moment like you are maybe losing the
grip of the position or were you
comfortable the whole game uh not at all
but of course I was not calm because
it's never easy to win a chess game of
course there's always chances for the
opponent fortunately he was never within
the drawing margins so uh he just never
got chances but he fought well I would
say
well congratulations and good luck in
the rest of the tournament thank you
very much absolutely and let's just go
to our